- Which one of you mother****ers
is coming in second?
Never accept the
limitations of someone else!
You have to start, with the belief,
that you can do (bleep) do somethin'.
Get yo punk ass up off the couch,
and get out into that goddamn gym!
I mean, out of pain, we are born!
If you can't commit, to this (bleep),
(bleep) you.
CT Fletcher is here,
for the competition, for
all intensive purposes,
for you, it's over!
Never, ever become satisfied!
If you give me everything
you got, all of it,
every bit of it, you cannot fail!
She shooed 'em away,
and she grilled her (bleep)
self across that finished line!
- He's a powerlifter, from
Long Beach, California.
- He's a six time world
champion powerlifter!
- He co-owns Metroflex Gym
Long Beach, where he trains.
- He's CT Fletcher,
and here are his top
ten rules for success.
- Which one of you mother****ers
is comin' in second?
(audience laughing)
(laughs) You didn't think
I was gon' do it, did ya?
You thought, oh, he's on CNN!
I know he ain't gon' say mother******.
(audience laughing)
I fooled you!
I fooled you.
To thine own self, be true.
So, to myself, I had to be true.
I'm not 'gon litter it,
because, yeah, I provide conversation,
with mother******s, and
****, as I usually do,
if you know anything about me.
I'm gon' limit 'em.
I'm gon' limit, maybe,
12, 13 mother*******,
through the whole thing!
Because, I would like, possibly,
to get a few seconds on CNN.
(audience laughing)
But, if I don't make it, **** it.
Listen up, (bleep)!
Question, question for yourself,
what is impossible?
Never accept the
limitations of someone else!
Somebody told you, that it's impossible!
Don't even try!
Give up, before you even
(bleep) try it for yourself!
Never accept the goddamn limitations,
that someone else is placed upon you!
Decide for your (bleep) self,
what is your limitation!
Try it, you son of a (bleep)!
Try it for your (bleep) self,
then that is the only
way, the only (bleep) way,
to know if you can, or can't do somethin'.
I gave it a (bleep) try!
That's how I know!
Get your punk ass in
there, and give it a try!
The most important thing
is, is this right here.
You must have, you have
to start with the belief,
that you can (bleep) do somethin'.
I mean, when (bleep) set out,
to go to the (bleep) moon,
some airhead (bleep) had to be believe,
that we can build this
goddamn rocket ship,
that can take us to the moon.
Some (bleep) had to come
up with this (bleep) idea,
and actually believe
he could (bleep) do it.
And the first (bleep) said,
who invented the goddamn wheel,
you know what,
I think there's a better
way of doin' this (bleep).
If I make this round (bleep)
put through sticks, between,
I think we can roll it around,
a little (bleep) faster.
The rest of the cavemen
was lookin' at that son of a (bleep),
like he was a idiot!
Are you (bleep) crazy?
It'll never work!
But, if it wasn't for
that (bleep) lunatic,
idiot (bleep), we'd all
be still walkin' around.
Some (bleep) has to be
the (bleep) that says,
I believe we can do this (bleep).
Be the (bleep), that has the new idea!
Be the (bleep), who believes,
that he can do shit,
when all these other
idiots say you can't do it!
I want to be that (bleep)!
I want to be him!
I identify with him!
That (bleep) was the first
(bleep), to do (bleep),
that innovative (bleep)
So, when I was invited here
today, and they said, clever,
I say to myself, hmm,
I don't think my approach,
in the industry that I am
in, the fitness industry,
would be considered clever.
Because, in this day
and age, in this time,
it's a push, or a training,
toward easier is better.
The easier way, the easier approach.
Five minute abs, four
minute abs, two minute...
One minute abs.
(audience laughing)
Now, you're gon' think I'm making this up,
but I'd seen an ad the
other day, for a belt.
You just put it around your waistline...
And you can sit on your
computer, and watch Netflix,
chat with your boyfriend, or girlfriend,
donkey, or whatever it is you talk to...
(audience laughing)
And it will work your abs, for you!
Wow!
That's cool!
I just sit there,
and this machine will work my abs for me.
I don't have to do one sit-up, one crunch!
Cover their ears, cover their ears!
Not one, not one!
And here, I come along, old
crusty old man, 55 years old,
and I look you in the eyeballs,
pointin' my finger in your face,
and I say, **** that!
(audience laughing)
Get yo punk ass up off the couch,
and get out into that goddamn gym,
and work for what you want!
So, I don't know,
if that would be
considered clever, or not.
What do you think?
Pain is necessary!
It's inescapable!
It's no way!
I mean, out of pain, we are born!
Pain is a must!
Pain, it is necessity of growth!
Be comfortable, with being uncomfortable!
Pain is a necessary evil!
Get used to it, (bleep)!
Make friends with it, and
then kick (bleep) pain's ass!
And that way, when it
comes, to take you down,
you can brush that (bleep) (bleep) off!
I'm used to you, (bleep)!
Bring it on, come on, pain!
Sit yo ass down, and let's
have a (bleep) lunch together!
Me and you, pain, let's do it!
Best (bleep) friends!
(bleep) your excuses.
Be committed.
If you can't commit, to
this (bleep), (bleep) you.
If you don't know what
total commitment is,
if you don't know, if you
don't want it that bad again,
if you haven't made up
in your mind yet, enough,
that you're totally committed,
to let me kick your (bleep)
ass, then stay at home.
Do us both a (bleep) favor,
and just stay yo (bleep) ass at home,
sittin' on the couch, eatin' a bonbon,
with the (bleep) little,
flashy little house shoes on.
This is my job!
This is what I like to do!
This what I do!
I motivate (bleep), who
want to be motivated.
You don't want to be motivated,
leave me the (bleep) alone.
I'd rather (bleep) die,
doing what I love to do,
than sit at home, talking
about what I should be doin'.
Oh, damn, one of these days,
I'm going to get up and do this,
though I should go do that.
You know, I'm going to get up!
One of these days, I'm
going to go to the gym,
I'm going to work out.
(bleep) that.
I would rather (bleep) die, on
the bench press, or curling,
or sprained knee, doing what I love to do,
than (bleep) talking
about what I might do,
or what I should do.
That's the difference, between me and you.
I'm a doer.
You're a (bleep) talker.
I used to walk into a competition,
and I would say, I am the one!
Which one of you guys is comin' in second,
'cause all of you ************* know,
CT Fletcher is here!
For the competition, for all
intensive purposes, for you,
it's over!
(audience laughing)
'Cause, first place...
****, that's mine.
That's a guarantee, that's a lock!
So, you can discuss amongst
yourselves, come to a decision,
which one of you all comin'
in second, and third.
That's okay with me!
But, this top podium...
That belongs to me.
Why, because not one
of you can out-will me.
You may have been born,
with more genetic prowess than I have,
but you cannot out-determine me!
You can't out-will me.
You can't out-want me!
You can't outwork me.
You can't out-desire me!
I'm the king of that ****!
And that's why, this top
spot, this number one...
That's mine.
You guys go ahead, and
fight over second and third.
But, I know, tell me, from
that type of attitude,
I really felt, like I was the
strongest man on the earth!
What you see here, before
you, today, is leftovers.
I'm 55.
Every bone in my body ache.
(audience laughing)
But, I'm still CT mother****** Fletcher.
I'm big enough, I'm satisfied.
Never, ever become satisfied!
Satisfaction...
Is the death blow.
It's the end of the line!
You cannot progress
farther, than satisfaction.
Satisfaction is the end of your growth!
It is the end of your journey!
It's over for you, (bleep)!
I am satisfied, I no
longer need to struggle!
I no longer need to push myself!
I'm done!
I have reached my goal!
(bleep) satisfaction!
Am I satisfied?
Not by a long (bleep) shot!
(laughs) Is my journey over?
(bleep) no!
And I (bleep) will not go
quietly, until the night!
I will go, kickin', and (bleep) screamin'!
(bleep) satisfaction!
(bleep) it!
(bleep) average!
If it's one thing, I (bleep) can't stand,
and that's a average (bleep).
(bleep) average.
Are you going to be the
beast, or a (bleep)?
You make the call (bleep)!
It ain't up to me!
It's up to you!
You gon' be a sorry bunch
of bleedin' lookin' (bleep),
in your whole entire life?
You cotton candy-eatin' (bleep)!
The (bleep) up, and do some work!
Grab yo goddamn bootstraps!
Tighten your (bleep) belt up,
and get yo (bleep) ass in
your gym, and do somethin'!
You going to be a hip havin' (bleep),
in your whole entire life?
Ain't you been a (bleep) pacified,
suckin' (bleep) long enough, (bleep)?
Don't you think it's time,
to do somethin' about that?
Step through the looking glass!
I'm not givin' you no (bleep),
Alex stay in your, hell no!
Right now, (bleep)!
And you bring that (bleep)!
Ball your (bleep) fist up,
and knock somethin' the (bleep) out!
Don't let that (bleep) iron rule you!
It's a piece of (bleep) iron!
It's a inanimate object!
You command that (bleep)!
That's why, I'm number one,
'cause I'm willin' to do
what you ain't willin' to do!
All you want to do, is talk
(bleep) about what I'm doin'.
But, you know what, (bleep)?
I'm doin' somethin'!
I got my (bleep) ass in here,
and I'm doin' my (bleep) best!
That's all I ask, from anyone
of you empty headed (bleep),
is to give me everything that you got!
If you give me everything you got,
all of it, every bit of it,
you cannot fail, (bleep)!
It's impossible, for you to fail!
(bleep) average!
Unchain your mind.
Unchain your mind, from
the imprisonment of fear!
Unchain your mind!
It's been encaged, with doubt!
Unchain your mind, loose yourself!
Let yourself free, from
the binds of average,
from the binds of normal!
Loose yourself, from intimidation!
Let yourself free!
Let your mind go!
Shift your focus!
Your focus, your intensity,
your drive, your everything,
should be put into the amount,
the amount of effort,
that you are going to
put into that attempt!
You cannot fail!
You cannot fail, if you give
100 percent of your effort,
you (bleep)!
You cannot fail!
It is impossible!
There was a lady, I don't
even remember the lady's name,
but I remember her act!
She came in, absolutely
last in a marathon.
Everybody had crossed the finish line!
She was the last person, in the stadium!
The lights was gettin' dark,
and she fell down, 25 yards
before the finish line!
But, that lady (bleep) crawled!
She crawled!
People tried to rush out, and help her!
The medics came out,
and tried to help her.
But, she shooed 'em away!
She shooed 'em away,
and she grilled her (bleep)
self across that finish line!
That is the kind of attitude,
that I want you to have!
That's what you focus on!
You focus on givin' that
(bleep) everything you got
within you!
Every drop of energy,
every drop of strength,
every drop of intensity,
every drop of testicular
fortitude, that I can muster!
I'm gon' give it every
(bleep) thing I got!
(bleep) what ifs!
You always have power,
over the amount of effort,
that you put into whatever
the (bleep) you are doing!
Because, you know, the
only mission that I have,
the only goals that I have,
the only determination that I will make,
is that I'm going to give this (bleep)
every goddamn thing within me!
Break the goddamn chains,
break your chains!
Let yourself be free!
Go out there, and (bleep) lay waste!
Destroy some (bleep)!
Unchain your mind!
- Thank you so much, for watching!
- We made this video,
because PO asked us to.
Once again, if you have
any famous entrepreneurs,
that you want us to profile next,
please leave it, in a comment below.
- We'd also love to know which
of CT Fletcher's top ten
rules meant the most to you,
hit you the hardest!
Leave it in the comments
below, and join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- I'm coming from a position,
of being the best, at what I chose to do.
My chosen field, I was the best at that.
And the way I approached,
being the best at that...
My message travels
throughout whatever industry,
whatever chosen field, that you choose,
and whatever endeavor you
choose, to take upon yourself.
If you want to be the best, at that.
If you want to reach the
pinnacle, of that, you must be!
There's no way around it.
You have to be...
Obsessed, with obtaining that!
Greatness, in any field!
Greatness cannot be
achieved, without obsession.
Yeah, I said ****!
(audience laughing)
I said it!
I said it, and I mean that.
I stand on that.
If you want to be the best,
you must be obsessed with it.
He had a slide up, a moment ago,
Orville and Wilbur Wright.
Do you think they wasn't
obsessed with flying?
Keep fooling yourself.
They were obsessed with that.
JP Morgan.
CEOs.
Even, talk show hosts.
Even, anchormen!
If you want to be the best
anchorman, you must be!
You have no choice!
There's no other way around it!
There's no easy way to do it!
You have to be obsessed, with that shit.
Can't get away from it.
Obsession.
My recovery was hard!
I prayed, to God, I told Him,
if this shit gon' be
like this, much longer,
then just take me out!
Don't let me, I don't
want to live like this!
I can't live like this!
Just let me die, because
the shit is rough!
But, you know what, I didn't die.
I kept livin'!
A doctor came in, to me, in the hospital.
He said, "I heard, CT, that you're
"a three-time world champion!"
I said, yes doctor, I am.
And he said, "Well..."
He shook his head, a young
guy, he shook his head,
and he said, "Man, what happened to you?"
I'll tell you what,
I want to thank that (bleep) doctor,
for askin' me, what happened to me.
He asked me, what happened to
me, with disdain in his eyes.
He couldn't believe, that I
had fell that (bleep) far,
because I looked like a
(bleep) human skeleton!
He just couldn't believe it!
"CT, what happened to you?
"You don't look like
you ever lift a weight,
"in your whole (bleep) life!"
But, that doctor, is
what made me determined,
to get back out there,
and to climb back up,
to the top of the (bleep) mountain,
and be king of the
(bleep) beasts, once more!
He, I thank you, doctor!
You made me do this (bleep)!
Asked me what happened?
(bleep) you, (bleep), I'mma
show yo ass what happened!
My mom used to tell me,
all the time, sometimes...
If you just a little bit too high,
gettin' a little too full of yourself,
you must be brought down!
You will be taught a (bleep) lesson!
And I've seen it, I... (exclaims)
Not me!
But, she said, "I don't
care how bad you are, son!
"If somebody else out there,
just a little bit badder,"
I said, no.
Hell no!
Mama, somebody got to be the baddest!
Somebody got to be the baddest!
Mama, I love you, but that's me.